[Musique]
jeudi dernier un terrible incendie qui
heureusement n'a fait aucune victime
avantage et une partie de lusine
lubrizol de roue en générant un immense
nuage noir qui s'est abattue sur une
partie de la seine maritime et au delà
merci vraiment aux forces de l'ordre aux
salariés de l'usiné et à nos pompiers
car le pire a été évité mais j'ai les
habitants une légitime angoisse et
colère demeurent les enquêtes
judiciaires administratives doivent
rapidement déterminer les
responsabilités mais là c'est la santé
qui prime
des réponses précises et des
explications claires sont attendus lors
de votre venue monsieur le premier
ministre vous vous êtes engagé à la
transparence
elle est garantie par l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement
hier le préfet dévoilé des chiffres
alarmants 5253 tonnes de produits
chimiques brûlé 160 fut toujours
entreposés en état délicat il faut que
les prochaines analyses nous renseigne
sur les molécules dégagé qui ont été
inhalé les retombés dessus et leurs
conséquences nos familles sont inquiètes
vous avez reconnu la nécessité d'un
suivi médical de long terme il faut
aussi un suivi épidémiologique strictes
qui doit s'appliquer à ceux qui sont
intervenus sur le sinistre ainsi qu'à
toute la population touchée d'une
manière ou d'une autre
si comme vous le dites l'état de
catastrophe technologique n'est pas
envisagée quel est alors votre solution
pour indemniser les victimes
je remercie didier guillaume qui a
reconnu la gravité de la situation et
promis des aides à nos agriculteurs
éleveurs et maraîchers des 206 commune
de normandie et des hauts de france
impacté par la suspension des récoltes
et des collectes de lait enfin lorsqu'un
événement de cette gravité ampleur se
produit il faut que l'ensemble des
maires soient bien informés ils nous ont
dit regretter de n'avoir pas toujours pu
jouer leur rôle auprès de la population
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
lundi soir nous étions tous les deux et
avec d'autres parlementaires sénateurs
et députés sur le site et pour mesurer
l'ampleur de l'incendié
je voudrais aller dans le sens de ce que
vous avez indiquée madame la présidente
pour dire que cet incendie très
spectaculaire et graves a été maîtrisé
en 12 heures sans victimes et 100
blessés grâce à l'exceptionnelle qualité
de l'intervention des pompiers
je répondrai sur tous les points que
vous avez évoquées madame la présidente
je voudrais que ici au sénat et je sais
que vous le mesurer parfaitement
on songe bien à la qualité
exceptionnelle de ses internautes
invention qui en douze heures a permis
d'éviter l'effet domino la l'expansion
du feu qui d'une zone de stockage aurait
pu aller jusqu'à des zones de production
avec des conséquences qui auraient été
bien plus grave
cela a été empêché grâce à une
remarquable mobilisation des services de
l'état
grâce à une remarquable coordination
entre les salariés du site et les forces
de l'ordre et les forces de secours
et encore une fois toutes les questions
vous avez posées sont légitimes mais
gardons à l'esprit
l'exceptionnelle qualité de ce travail
de cette première réponse je comprends
madame la présidente parfaitement
l'émotion
l'inquiétude qui peut aller jusqu'à la
colère des rouennais et au delà
d'ailleurs de tous les habitants de la
métropole et de tous les habitants des
communes qui ont vu passer le nuage ou
qui s'interrogent sur les conséquences
de ce nuage sur leur santé je redis le
plus clairement et le plus fermement
l'engagement absolu du gouvernement de
l'état à la transparence totale complète
toutes les informations toutes les
données scientifiques qui seront rendues
disponibles par les analyses mise en
oeuvre seront communiqués au public tout
le principe de précaution a été appliqué
avec vigilance
dès le premier jour des recommandations
claires ont été formulées et je vous
entends volontiers madame la présidente
quand vous dites que dans la diffusion
de l'information
le préfet l'a reconnu je veux lui dire
mon soutien
car son action était délicate mais le
reconnu le préfet reconnu lui-même dans
une rencontre avec les maires de la
métropole rennaise que la qualité de
l'information aux premières heures de
l'évènement à destination d'un certain
nombre de mères n'avaient peut-être pas
été à la hauteur des aspirations
légitimes formulées par les magistrats
les premiers magistrats de leur commune
et donc de ce point de vue là les
retours d'expérience que nous aurons à
conduire pour apprendre de cet événement
mettra en évidence sans doute
l'amélioration qu'il faut porter sur ce
point mais les consignes de vigilance
ont été immédiatement donnée nous avons
fait procéder au nettoyage de toutes les
écoles avant leur réouverture lundi une
campagne de surveillance approfondie de
l'ensemble des impacts environnementaux
dans l'eau dans l'air dans les sols avec
des prélèvements a débuté dès vendredi
dès vendredi les résultats sont et
seront rendus publics au fur et à mesure
de leur arrivée en fonction des produits
qui sont testés en fonction de la
difficulté technique de ses analyses ses
analyses peuvent prendre plus de temps
mais elles seront toutes rendues
publiques
j insiste j'ai demandé au préfet de
normandie de rendre compte au public
chaque jour en fin d'après-midi de
l'avancée des travaux
à l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
il sera appuyé par une cellule nationale
d'appui scientifique car beaucoup de
questions techniques environnementales
ou médicales sont posées et il faut
apporter à ces questions techniques
environnementales ou médicales des
réponses précises c'est la raison pour
laquelle le directeur général de
l'ineris un expert de santé publique
france le chef du service de pneus
pneus mollo j du chu de rouen seront
associés à ces prises de parole afin de
pouvoir répondre le plus précisément
possible aux questions qui ne manqueront
pas d'être posée hier
hier soir hier en fin d'après-midi le
préfet a rendu publique la liste
complète des produits présents dans
l'entrepôt qui a brûlé avec les
caractéristiques de ces produits et les
risques associés
je veux sur ce point être clair mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs depuis la fin
de l'année 2017 et pour des raisons de
sécurité qui n'échapperont à personne la
liste complète des substances autorisées
sur les sites seveso n'était plus
rendues publiques mais dans tous les cas
dans tous les cas cette liste ne dit
rien des produits et des quantités qui
sont réellement présents sur le site
à un moment donné la liste que nous
avons rendu public hier et précise elle
donne les produits qui étaient
effectivement présents dans l'entrepôt
qui a brûlé dans l'entrepôt qui a brûlé
avec leur quantité
l'état a pu recevoir la liste précise
mardi matin nous l'avons publié dans la
journée sur la base de cette liste
l'ineris landes cesse seront saisis
aujourd'hui pour faire des
recommandations sur des produits
supplémentaires à rechercher dans l'air
ou dans les suit le dames et messieurs
laissez nous ne savons pas tout
aujourd'hui parce que les analyses sont
en cours
et parce qu'il va falloir les poursuivre
et pendant longtemps nous ne savons pas
tout aujourd'hui ce que nous savons
d'ores et déjà sur la qualité de l'air
c'est que tous les prélèvements dans
l'air dont nous disposons à cette heure
et qui sont publics font apparaître un
état habituel de la qualité de l'air sur
le plan sanitaire à l'extérieur du site
les analyses complémentaires ont été
engagés pour vérifier si des fibres
d'amiante sont présentes dans l'air
parce que la toiture des bâtiments qui
ont brûlé en contenait les premiers
résultats pour les mesures faites dans
un rayon de 300 mètres autour du site
ont été rendus publics hier il montre qu
aucune fibre n'a été détectée dans les
prélèvements de surface et qu'il n'y a
pas d'anomalie sur les prélèvements dans
l'air d'autres résultats sur des zones
plus éloignées vont suivre dans les
prochains jours et évidemment ils seront
rendus publics
je n'ignore pas les odeurs incommodantes
qui perturbe qui perdurait encore hier
j'ai parfaitement conscience qu'elle
gêne j'ai parfaitement conscience
qu'elles inquiètent la population mais
les résultats connus des mesures d'air
permettent aux autorités sanitaires ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les
autorités sanitaires d'affirmer que ces
odeurs ne présente pas de risque pour la
santé les services de l'état travaillent
d'ailleurs avec l'entreprise pour
résorber et source d'odeur comme
l'indiquait le préfet mardi les
opérations nettoyage du suite du site
sont en cours et une protection sera
installée sur la zone contenant des fûts
endommagée pour capter les flux d'air je
voudrais terminer je voudrais vous prier
monsieur le président cette réponse trop
longue mais compte tenu de l'émotion je
crois qu'il croit qu'il est important
que au travers aujourd'hui c'est une à
l'ensemble de la population soit
informée je vous remercie de pouvoir
préciser les choses de la façon la plus
claire possible
vous avez évoqué madame la présidente la
possibilité de faire reconnaître l'état
de catastrophe technologique et un
certain nombre d'élus rouennais m'ont
saisi de cette possibilité offerte par
une loi de 2003 la loi bachelot de 2003
qui a créé cette possibilité a mis en
place par cette fois un régime
d'indemnisation des victimes de
catastrophes technologie ce régime
je le dis au sénat vise à faciliter le
traitement des accidents qui ont eu un
très fort impact sur les biens
immobiliers et mobiliers en s'appuyant
sur le précédent d'azf à toulouse en
2001 pour lequel des milliers de
logements avaient été impactées voire
rendus inutilisables
dans le cas présent le dispositif tel
qu'il a été conçu les critères qui ont
été posées par la loi même ne semble pas
en première analyse adapté à ce que nous
vivons pas complètement adaptée
il n'y a pas eu de dommages importants
sur les logements dans l'environnement
du site et le dispositif ne concerne
d'ailleurs pas l'indemnisation des
producteurs agricoles dans tous les cas
et je veux le dire
car il y à un acteur que nous n'avons
pas encore mentionné dans tous les cas
je veillerai à ce que les mesures prises
pour l'indemnisation immédiate des
agriculteurs qui voient leur production
en vertu du principe de précaution
non commercialisé les riverains
l'ensemble de ceux qui subissent un
préjudice ou un dommage je veillerai à
ce que rien ne vienne exonérer la
responsabilité de l'industriel
car en fait d'installations classées le
régime juridique qui a été posé par la
loi est complétée par la loi prévoit
qu'il ya bien un responsable
l'entreprise
l'acteur industriel qui est responsable
des dommages causés au voisinage du fait
des activités à l'intérieur du site
industriel s'agissant de la demande et
je conclus par là s'agissant de la
demande de mettre en place un suivi
médical de long terme ou une étude et
piste et une pardon et une étude
épidémiologique en la matière la réponse
est évidemment que comme pour la
transparence le gouvernement et l'état
mettra tout en oeuvre pour dire pour
mesurer et pour faire connaître
l'ensemble des causes et des
conséquences de cet incendie de cette
catastrophe industrielle dont nous
souhaitons et dont nous allons veiller à
ce qu'elle ne devienne pas une
catastrophe sanitaire ou une catastrophe
environnementale
dams et messieurs les sénateurs je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser le temps
que j'ai pris pour répondre à cette
question mais il me semble important
d'aller jusqu'au bout mais merci
monsieur le premier ministre
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
premier ministre de vos réponses vous
l'avez reconnu la crise est grave les
sanitaires écologiques économiques
elle nous interpelle sur la sécurité des
sites seveso en général ça ne lui bien
préparés à gérer c'est que les
industriels même si nos pompiers étaient
absolument extraordinaire vous l'avez
dit toutes les leçons utiles et potel
été tirées des cdf c'est une question
nous allons prendre nos responsabilités
aussi au sénat créer une commission
denquête mais mes chers collègues ou de
contrôle commune qui nous permettra un
suivi très strict de cette situation et
des analyses qui nous seront utiles pour
progresser et faire en sorte un tel
drame ne se reproduise plus tu vous
remercie il ya six jours l'agglomération
de rouen a vécu la plus importante
catastrophe industrielle connue depuis
le drame d'azf en 2001
l'incendié de l'usiné brise hall a
généré un gigantesque nuage de fumée
noire épaisse et nauséabonde dont les
particules ont tapissé jardin cour
d'école habitations et récolte
constituant une véritable marée noire
terrestre le pire a été évité grâce au
courage 240 sapeurs-pompiers au
personnel de lusine dont je salue le
dévouement
mais monsieur le ministre la gestion de
cette crise n'a pas été satisfaisante
les maires ont été livrés à eux-mêmes
sirène d'alert actionnait tardivement
absence d'information dans certaines
communes pourtant très proches du
sinistre consignes de confinement
confuse cacophonie totale quant à
l'ouverture ou la fermeture des
établissements scolaires les
communications distillées au fil des
heures se voulaient rassurantes elles
ont produit l'effet inverse et la colère
a empli le vide d'information
comment croire qu'il n'ya pas de danger
quand le préfet annonce qu'il n'y a pas
de risque de toxicité aiguë
reconnaissant implicitement que les
fumées sont bien toxiques
comment accepter qu'il n'y ait aucun
risque lorsque l'état public tardivement
la liste des produits partis en fumée et
que l'on en connaît ni la quantité ni la
résistance à la chaleur ni la
dangerosité
comment se sentir en sécurité quand
hires 165 fut endommagée qui peuvent
dégager du sulfure d'hydrogène hautement
toxiques
comment être rassurés lorsque les
agriculteurs de 206 communes ne sont
toujours pas autorisés à procéder aux
récoltes vendre leur lait et leurs
produits agricoles monsieur le premier
ministre pour apaiser la colère et les
angoisses
nous vous demandons d'accéder aux
demandes suivantes la transparence vous
y êtes engagés nous vous en remercions
la nomination est un comité d'experts
indépendants chargé d'analyser et
d'interpréter les résultats des études
sera la bienvenue
la mise en place d'un suivi médical à
court et long terme
la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe technologique qui
permettrait d'ouvrir droit à
indemnisation
même si les biens n'ont pas été détruits
et la réparation rapide des dommages en
ordonnant préfet d'exercer ses
prérogatives de police administrative et
d'appliquer le principe de
pollueur-payeur
sans attendre l'issue des procédures
judiciaires qui prendront des années il
faut rétablir la confiance et la
sérénité en faisant preuve de sérieux et
de responsabilité et ses propositions
formulées avec une centaine d'élus
peuvent-ils contribuer au nomme monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur didier
marie je vous ai indiqué à l'occasion de
la réponse que je formule et à madame la
présidente mans un desailly les
engagements pris par le gouvernement de
transparence totale je vous ai dit que
nous donnions les éléments qui sont en
notre possession au fur et à mesure que
nous les avons et vous comprendrez bien
je ne veux pas prendre le sujet à la
légère que je ne peux pas produire les
résultats des analyses avant qu'elles
aient été réalisés lorsque vous tester
un certain nombre de prélèvements pour
vérifier la présence éventuelle de
dioxine ça prend du temps
ce n'est pas moi qui le dis je ne suis
pas chimiste c'est les gens qui font ces
analyses les spécialistes qui les font
bien parce qu'ils doivent donner une
information sérieuse et précises et je
pense que vous et moi nous accordons
parfaitement sur ce point dès que nous
les avons nous les communiquent au j'ai
parfaitement conscience qu'au fur et à
mesure que nous donnons des informations
de nouvelles questions se posent
et c'est bien naturel et nous ne nous
arrêterons pas à cela au contraire
toutes les informations qui seront
publiques qui seront connus seront
rendues publiques qu'elles susciteront
de nouvelles questions de nouvelles
interrogations parfois peut-être de
nouvelles angoisses et nous y répondrons
car j'ai parfaitement conscience
monsieur le sénateur que la parole est
parfois les expertises publiques sont
contestées et que certains dès lors que
je dirais ou que quiconque du monde
administratif ou politiques s'expriment
sur un sujet ne serait pas crédible
je le sais je le mesure et je le déplore
mais je ne vais pas pour cela commencer
à raconter n'importe quoi ou arrêter de
donner les informations donc nous allons
faire exactement ce que je me suis
engagé à faire donner au fur et à mesure
qu'elles sont disponibles
absolument toutes les informations dans
les questions et dans les demandes que
vous avez formulées monsieur le sénateur
j'ai déjà dit oui et je leur dis
volontiers à cette tribune
oui à la transparence totale bien
entendu bien entendu oui au suivi
épidémiologique est au bilan de santé à
court et à long terme bien entendu car
il faut être précis
oui à la discussion scientifique des
éléments qui seront données par les
analyses vous me permettrez de dire que
c'est d'abord allende cesse à l'ineris
aux hôpitaux de donner les éléments et
de répondre à des questions mais par
définition ces informations et en public
elles seront discutées peut être
contesté par d'autres scientifiques ou
d'autres médecins cette discussion ne me
fait pas peur elle est nécessaire alors
a lieu et nous expliquerons vous
m'interrogez sur l'état de catastrophe
technologique
je comprends et je vois bien l'intérêt
qu'il pourrait y avoir à reconnaître
officiellement qu'une catastrophe a eu
lieu à l'évidence une catastrophe oeil
mais l'instrument juridique tel qu'il a
été conçu par le parlement en 2003 ne
répond manifestement en rien ni aux
caractéristiques ni aux questions que
pose l'accident qui a eu lieu sur le
site de lubrizol est donc je ne veux pas
en la matière et je pense que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi je ne veux pas me
payer de mots je veux dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont et mettre en place
les dispositifs tels qu'ils existent et
surtout monsieur le sénateur je veux
dire et redire que la responsabilité
les dommages relève de l'industriel
c'est sa responsabilité et
et il n'échappera pas à la mise en jeu
de cette responsabilité car encore une
fois si toute la législation que vous
avez passé que vous avez produite sur
les installations classées un sens c'est
bien de dire qu'il y a un interlocuteur
l'acteur industrielle qui responsable
alors nous allons appliquer toute la loi
en la matière avec beaucoup de rigueur
et avec la totale transparence qui est
dû à nos concitoyens il convient de
prendre la pleine mesure des
conséquences sanitaires et des villes
inquiétudes écologiques et économiques
qui expriment les populations les
professionnels intervenus sur le site
des réponses claires elles sans
ambiguïté et qui relève de l'état se
sont par trop fait attendre
une communication brouillonne
inappropriée et inadaptée à donner le
sentiment d'une crise très mal gérée par
les pouvoirs publics
sonic ce qui n'a fait qu'accroître le
malaise trop de questions restent sans
réponse aussi je vous demande madame la
ministre de faire la lumière sur
plusieurs zones d'ombré les leçons de
l'incident survenu en 2013 on et elles
ont elles été tirées et si oui selon
quel plan d'action les réglementation
seveso ont elles été intégralement
respectés et si oui
sont-elles à la hauteur des défis
sanitaires pourquoi avoir attendu cinq
longues journées pour publier la liste
des produits chimiques présents sur le
site de lubrizol
cette liste est elle d'ailleurs complète
enfin au delà des premiers résultats de
l'ineris d'autres analyses sont en cours
vous engagez vous allez rendre tout est
intégralement publics
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs us ont je voudrais vous redire
l'extrême mobilisation des services de
secours et des services de l'état pour
faire face à cette catastrophe
industrielle
je voudrais à nouveau rendre hommage aux
pompiers et aux services qui ont été
mobilisés dès le début de l' incendie
qui ont permis de
maîtriser cet incendie d'éviter tout sur
accident dans un contexte qui était
pourtant très compliqué je peux vous
assurer que les services de l'état sur
le terrain ont également été mobilisés
pour réaliser ou faire réaliser par
l'exploitant comme lui impose la loi
de nombreux prélèvements dans l'air dans
l'eau dans les sols sur les végétaux
dès que les résultats de ces analyses
sont connus ils sont rendus publics ils
ont été successivement vendredi samedi
ils continueront à l'être sur le site de
la préfecture sur les leçons de 2013
je peux vous confirmer qu'en effet c'est
le son bien été tiré et notamment sur le
fait que à l'époque les services de
secours les services de l'état ne
disposait pas d'une capacité à faire
réaliser des prélèvements et des
analyses avec autant de réactivité et je
pense que si nous avons pu disposer de
ces informations
aussi rapidement c'est bien parce que
nous en avons tiré les conséquences de
l'incident 2013 alors forcément comme
dans tout accident dans une catastrophe
telle que celle que nous avons connue à
rouen nous aurons encore à progresser
nous auront à examiner notamment
pourquoi cet incendie s'est déclaré dans
un site qui est pourtant très surveillé
trente neuf inspections ont été
réalisées depuis 2000 13 10 au cours des
deux dernières années
mais forcément cet incendie n'aurait pas
dû se produire et donc nous aurons est
certainement votre commission denquête
nous éclairera également à en tirer les
conséquences aux anciens merci madame la
ministre
la parole publique qu'elles proviennent
en l'occurrence de l'état ou de
l'exploitant a été défaillante dans ce
cas depuis le départ entretenir le flou
par la cacophonie les déclarations
officielles contradictoires n'est pas
acceptable et symbolise une crise
ingérable face au discrédit de la parole
publique
notez-bien en effet madame la ministre
quand cinq jours pas moins de cinq
ministres dont vous-même et le premier
ministre sont venus sur place pour y
tenir cinq discours différent accentuant
le trouble dans l'opinion
enfin et je veux le dire ici les
préoccupations écologiques et
environnementales
parce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui dans la
conscience des français mérite qu'on en
partage les défis et les enjeux en toute
transparence nous avons et l'état au
premier chef à devoir de vérité chacun
le constatera il reste beaucoup à faire
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres vous
avez enfin accepté de publier la liste
des produits stockés chez lubrizol
mais j'imagine et j'espère que les
services de l'état ont disposé alors
pourquoi ne pas avoir fait évaluer dès
les premières heures de l'instant dit
les conséquences sur la santé humaine
celle des animaux sur l'air l'eau les
sols ou les cultures de la combustion de
ce cocktail de sus de substances face
aux effets sur la santé des populations
touchées
quel plan d'action sanitaire qu'elle
suivit épi dieu épidémiologie comptez
vous concrètement mettre en oeuvre
qu'est-il prévu pour les salariés
présents sur le site
lors de la dent lincendie pour les
sapeurs pompiers ou les forces de
l'ordre qui sont intervenues qui ont mis
leur vie en jeu et qui ont souvent
l'impression comme nos concitoyens
qu'ils courent de grands risques
les élus locaux seront finalement réunis
comme nous le demandons pouvez-vous nous
garantir qu'ils seront désormais
consultés et associés à chaque nouvelle
étape leur mise à l'écart l'isolement--
même le mépris qu'ils ont ressenties
sont inacceptables mais surtout contre
productif vous vous êtes privés d'acteur
majeur dans la gestion de la crise
lusine lubrizol a bénéficié de feu ce
que vous appelez des simplification de
la législation
ce sont en réalité un détricotage du
droit d'environnement et un recul des
exigences de sûreté en l'occurrence
l'augmentation des stocks sans étude de
dangers allez vous abandonnez vos
projets d'alléger encore les obligations
d'évaluation environnementale pour les
sites industriels sans attendre la
commission la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale dont nous nous réjouissons
nous voulons et la population veut des
réponses précises à ses questions
précises pour vous répondre la parole et
à la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire vadam bornes
avaient la parole je suis président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice céline brun brulin
excusez moi tout d'abord comme le
premier ministre et d'autres collègues
je me suis rendu sur le site et donc je
mesure pleinement à la fois l'émotion et
l'inquiétude des populations qui ont été
touchés par cette catastrophe
industrielle et donc je voudrais vous
redire l'engagement du gouvernement à
agir avec la plus grande exigence et
avec une transparence totale
c'est dans cet esprit que dès le début
de l'incendié des mesures ont été
réalisées à la fois sur l'air sur les
retombées du panache de fumée donc sur
les suit qui se sont déposées
donc ces mesures cette surveillance de
l'environnement
elle est faite depuis le départ les
analyses dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
on fait apparaître qu'il n'y avait pas
de de concentration anormale de produits
que ce soit dans l'air ou dans les suit
qui ont été analysées alors
effectivement le préfet a publié hier la
liste des produits qui avait qui se
trouvaient sur le site incendié sur la
partie incendiée du site qui représente
15% du site
cette liste elle a dû être établi à
notre demande par l'industriel parce que
comme vous le savez les autorisations
donc ceux demeurant plus public pour les
raisons exprimées par le premier
ministre portent sur la totalité du site
et ce qui était recherché c'était la
liste des produits sur la partie
incendiée du site qui a donc été
diffusée dès qu'elle nous a été remise
par l'industriel et sur cette base avec
agnès buzyn nous allons saisir landes
cesse et l'ineris pour savoir s'il faut
faire des analyses supplémentaires en
tout cas sur tous ces sujets moi je peux
vous assurer de la totale détermination
du gouvernement à assurer la plus grande
transparence à répondre à toutes les
questions des élus qui seront associés à
toutes les étapes du processus
bien évidemment comme nous voulons cette
transparence totale tous les éléments
pourront être fournis à la commission
denquête 6,8 secondes
merci monsieur le président je crois
qu'il faut que nous ayons collectivement
conscience que les réponses que vous
apportez et que je dirais que nous sont
répétés un peu en boucle ne répond pas à
la colère qui se développent parmi nos
concitoyens
il faut en tenir compte il ya une
aspiration immense à ce que l'état
protège
je crois que cette demande est légitime
et qu'il faut l'entendre et ils
répondent très concrètement je vous
remercie
[Musique]